[Music]
I've been living here for a few years
and I have an American son and so I
think I should do American activities
sure should we go to baseball you know
I'm talking out to his first baseball
and I'm a real fan of the Dodgers I'm
not like a fire by Night sort of guy all
right I go to lots of games I dress up I
wear the Jersey the whole outfit and
everything I showed up for the playoffs
and I had some tickets but it was for
the wrong game and so then I went to the
ticket booth and they said oh there's
some tickets left because the way I was
dressed like a player and my son was
dressed in the same outfit but strapped
to my chest yeah we were we were both
wearing Matt Camp jerseys right because
when my girlfriend was pregnant Matt
Kemp was still the Dodgers best player
in my child's lifetime Matt Kemp has
been injured the entire time uh other
babies are looking at my kid they're
wearing Puig jerseys like look at you
you idiot right so
we go up they say oh there's 900 tickets
that's all we've got left and I'm like
all right so I go and sit with the rich
people and the rich people in L.A they
they don't dress up so they already
don't want us there we're in the outfit
they're all coming in the third inning
and they're looking at us like we're
douchebags and all right but I sit there
and I'm doing fine
I was sitting there with myself and
there's drink service I didn't know you
get drink service very exciting they
bring you food right and I'm sitting
there and then they play The White
Stripes
I'm going to Wichita somehow that guy
makes the sound of Wichita sounds so
good yeah I really want to go to Wichita
yeah right and then they finish the song
and they they just they Jack White his
head's there and he's sitting there like
this no he's sitting there he's sitting
there in the stadium at the end of the
song everyone goes mental and then they
pan out
and sitting next to him you oh yeah okay
it was that's true it was obviously your
friends with Jack White yeah the whole
time I realized I've been in row three
and I couldn't see the game because
there was this big ginger head in front
of me
the whole time I've been sitting there
going how arrogant are this bus
what am I gonna do you should never sit
in the front of anything
disrespectful have you ever have you
ever been that guy that puts like
girlfriend on your shoulders at a
concert no I have not you shouldn't do
that oh yeah okay well I'm sorry I was
in front of you wait you should
you shoot 900
dollars saying a little bit of like a
Mexican guy than an Irish head and then
a right why didn't you at least come
down and say hi we've met each other
well this is the thing are we friends
yeah well we're not because we've only
met this I'd like to be friends I think
we have a good rapport of thing how
about that how about this we'll see how
about how about we go to a game with
Jack White one day the three of us
see we're not good friends you don't
want me to meet Jack White yet yeah
anyway so what I'm curious about is is
yeah you could have come down and I'm a
friendly guy well I was sitting there I
wanted to come down and I was sitting
there with my son he's fallen asleep the
whole time and and I had about four
beers into me and I said to my
girlfriend four beers and your son is
strapped he's strapped to my chest
and I said you could be my friend any
day
as much as I wanted to talk to you I I
really wanted to meet Jack White right
so I sat there with my girlfriend I
really want to meet Jack White and she's
like just go up you know Kona you and
Conan get along you can walk up and then
he'll introduce and then you'll all be
friends and I went no then I had another
two beers another couple of innings and
then I went me and Conan are friends
hahaha
I I get I can do this sure so my son's
like asleep now like he's slouched on
top of me and so I sort of slapped him
into anyway
the game's out at 10 it's very light for
him just pour your little beard down the
back of his neck well actually we have a
photo do you have a photo about a photo
of my son yeah
oh my God
[Applause]
[Music]
he does look like he's had a few yeah he
was he was struggling to take to keep up
yeah anyway so
so I get excited I go I'm gonna go meet
Jack White and so I walk out got my son
strapped to me and then I get up I walk
over to the road that you're at right so
I think Jack White's sitting here you're
sitting here right and I went hey and
you looked up at me with no recognition
not even the slightest hint of like even
like passing me in the street type of
recognition and I bottled it and I acted
like I was talking to someone five seats
on
and I went hey
Dave
yeah you know I'm just I'm just sitting
back there you know
I'll speak to you later all right
I went back and sat down I said that my
girlfriend she went how'd it go I go
you're the really nice guys
[Laughter]